- Welcome everyone, and
thank you for coming.
So, I'm Rohini Pande.
I'm a Professor of Economics,
and the Director of the
Economic Growth Center.
I also, together with
Dr. Charity Troyer Moore,
direct the Inclusion
Economics at Yale University.
Inclusion Economics is a policy
engaged research initiative
which seeks to promote
inclusive institutions,
economies, and societies.
So in that context,
we're particularly delighted
to have Barkha join us today,
who has really on the side of journalism
always sought to provide news,
and information that will help India,
and I think more broadly South Asia,
move towards being more inclusive.
Before I introduce Barkha,
let me start by saying that
we couldn't have done it
without our co-host, the
South Asia Studies Council,
and the Poynter Fellowship in Journalism.
Many thanks to Kasturi and Amaar at SASC,
and Bliss and Poynter team
for the help planning this.
Also a big thank you to Zahrah, Chris,
and Jenna who helped planned this event.
So let me now briefly introduce Barkha.
I think she probably needs
very little introduction
to the people in the room.
She's one of India's
best known journalists
who has reported for the
last 25 years from war zones,
and conflict areas across the world.
She's also the founding
editor of MoJo Story,
a multimedia digital platform,
and a columnist for the Washington Post.
She's received numerous awards,
but among them are the Padmashri,
and the Global Leader for Tomorrow
from the World Economic Forum.
To write her most recent book,
"To Hell and Back: Humans of COVID,"
Barkha made multiple pathbreaking
journeys across India
conducting ground reportage
during the pandemic.
And on tonight's event, she's
going to tell us about this.
I should also highlight that today's event
actually is a flipped
version of a policy dialogue
we had in Delhi in July
where researchers talked
about their findings
about the pandemic,
and then Barkha was part
of a discussion on it.
So today we are going to
continue the conversation
in a flipped version
with Barkha telling us about
her journey through COVID,
and her reflections through
through media in India today.
And then after that charity,
we'll provide some research insights
which complement Barkha's discussion.
Please join me in welcoming Barkha Dutt.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much.
You can all hear me?
- [Audience Member] We can.
- Okay, thank you for coming.
Thank you also to all of you
who may be part of this
conversation, but are online,
I hope to have it be an
interactive conversation.
So, looking for lots of questions,
and comments from the floor,
as well as questions coming
in from our audience online.
Okay, what I want to say
before I start talking
about my journey across India
is that reporting on COVID
really helped me understand many things
that I did not understand before
I embarked on this journey.
It helped me understand my country.
It helped me understand
how power is both wielded,
and organized structurally.
It helped me understand
my role as a journalist,
and in fact in particular
made me reexamine
what the place is of media,
independent media, not just in crisis,
but even at other times.
So when I wrote this book,
"To Hell and Back: Humans of COVID,"
above everything else for me,
for all of us who lived
through the pandemic,
we kept hearing things described
in terms of numbers, right?
Numbers are important.
Numbers help us actually get a very,
very empirical sense of what's going on.
But we would hear all the time dashboards
that would tell us caseload,
that would tell us
hospitalizations, mortalities,
and then later vaccine numbers,
and how many vaccines had been achieved,
and how many booster doses and so on.
But who were the people
behind these numbers?
Who were the people who
populated the numbers?
What were their stories?
What were their names?
Did we even know their names
and talking about numbers
would all of them even be counted?
I think that was at the heart
of my sort of journey across India.
And what I'm going to do
is to give you a sense
of what this in a way taught
me, what I had to unlearn.
As some of you might know,
I spent 20 plus years in television
before I moved to the digital media.
Some of you were at lunch today,
and we were talking about the
incredible shifts in India,
which mirror the shifts globally,
which is just to take you
through some of that data,
there are 650 million active
internet users in India.
70% of Indian servants say
they get their news content
today via the internet.
The top two sources of news
are YouTube and WhatsApp.
And there are serious questions today
over broken revenue models
in television newsrooms
as well as ownership
by big business houses
that raise questions over how free
they really are able to
be in their storytelling.
So for a combination of
reasons, shifting technology,
wanting to be my own boss,
disillusionment with talk TV shops,
which was what the state
of broadcast media was,
I shifted to forming my
own digital platform.
And as I had registered Mojo
Story, and Mojo means magic,
I set out to look for
the magic of journalism,
which I felt I had forgotten
and I wanted to rediscover.
Two months or three months
later the pandemic hit.
So my platform, and my life literally
for the last three years
has been consumed by the
telling of this story.
So, okay, yeah.
So lemme start with some images
that I think really captured
in a way the unique reality
of how COVID unfolded in India.
Unique because every country
negotiated COVID in its own ways.
In every country, COVID
exposed fault lines
that were unique to that country.
And in India, we had in the first wave
something unfold that we hadn't seen
actually since the partition of India,
which was the mass exodus,
and the mass movement of millions
of India's poorest citizens
or daily wage workers.
Now, why did this happen?
It happened simply because
like every other country
in the world, India decided to lock down.
But when we locked down,
we also closed public
transport in the first wave.
So in the first wave, you had no buses,
no trains, no airports,
you only had trucks
to some degree plying essential suppliers,
oil, grains and so on, and
that was pretty much it.
And what happened was
that though the government
issued orders saying that
workers, the poor workers,
who live on substance wages must be paid
nobody was paid because economic activity
had come to a grinding halt.
So these were men and women who,
for those of you who might be familiar
with Indian cities, think
of construction sites
where a house is coming up
or a factory is coming up.
They would live on the
site and be given temporary
like a shack to stay in
while the house was coming up
or they would work as help in the fields.
So they really had no homes
where they had migrated to.
They were just live in these
temporary sort of shelters.
They would get daily wages,
and suddenly they had no source of income.
Secondly, there was an
underestimation of the fact
that like you and me,
and I think it's easy to
forget this three years later,
but the first wave of COVID
felt like the end of the world.
You didn't know what
was gonna happen next.
We ran flights to bring some
of you back home to India,
the Vande Bharat Missions,
but no transport was actually
open for the poorest workers.
So they decided men, women,
and children to start walking home.
And these were some of the images
that I chronicled as I
followed them across India.
And what I really found
was that women in particular
had packed their universe's,
their entire universe into a little
what in Hindi is called a bori, a sack.
And and they were just,
they didn't know whether
they were gonna come back,
they didn't know if they
were ever going to come back,
were going to make it
to their destinations,
but their entire universe
packed into a little sack on their head.
Sometimes their infants
carried on their shoulders,
often with no food, a packet
of biscuits if they were lucky,
a small bottle of water
if they were lucky.
This is how they walked.
And they walked, as I said,
hundreds of kilometers often without shoes
in this coaching heat.
It was still extremely hot in North India
as they walked home.
To my shock, my (indistinct)
medium television.
And I'm a first generation TV journalist,
I'm a child of television.
I became a journalist when the airwaves
were privatized in India.
We only started having
private news in India in 1995.
So it's not that I sort of
was born heating television,
I was literally groomed by the medium,
shaped by the medium.
But to my absolute shock,
there was hardly any TV presence
with boots on the ground.
Television had decided
to basically look away
from these walking workers,
and concentrate on expert driven talk TV,
which had its place,
but was really not capturing
the scale of what was unfolding
on sort of the shiny express ways,
which at other moments were
actually an illustration
of how much India's infrastructure story
had improved and so on.
And so the story of
these daily wage workers
was told by independent
digital platforms like mine
by regional reporters
in the language press,
by Hindi newspapers,
and by what in my industry
are called stringers,
which are really not
professional journalists,
but let's say you live in a village,
and you have a smartphone,
you might decide to
take a bunch of pictures
of what you see,
and then you'll contribute
that to, let's say,
a big network headquartered
somewhere in the city.
Television effectively
just didn't get out,
it didn't get out of the metros,
and it sat in the studios.
In the meantime, we had
this sort of crisis unfold.
And in some cases,
and this is how I started discovering
the kind of structural
inequalities is that
at least my work,
I had been a war correspondent,
and then a political journalist.
So I'd done very little of this work,
and I had never really
looked at the issues
of structural inequalities
through a mainstream media lets.
And that is what I started doing here.
Now, where I'm sitting right now
is actually the premises
of a major factory
in India's capital Delhi.
And this was one of the
more extraordinary things
I encountered because the
owners of this factory
as these workers left the cities
to go back to their homes,
and the villages,
they decided that they
must stop the workers
from doing this, right?
And what they did
was they locked up the
workers behind these gates.
These were the locked
gates as we found them.
And we somehow managed
to force our way in,
and when we went we
actually found a board,
and the board actually listed the tours,
and the day that these workers
were allowed to come out
for a cup of tea, and a bathroom break.
I mean, it was literally
like locking up chattel,
like it was just horrendous.
And they were completely
tone deaf about it.
They actually thought
that they were looking after
the workers by doing this.
And when we walked in,
we found all of these
desolate, desperate people,
and they were like, "Get
us outta here somehow."
And when we started filming them,
we had guards come in,
confiscate our tapes,
try to lock us in.
Of course we made a whole lot of noise.
I started tweeting the chief minister,
we managed to get out of
there, but in some ways,
this was the beginning of my understanding
that till then there was a media cliche
that COVID was the great equalizer.
But in fact, COVID was the exact opposite
of the great equalizer.
Every structural inequity
of Indian society,
and I'm sure this was true globally,
but I can only speak to India
because that's what I reported on,
whether it was class, whether it was cast,
whether it was gender, it was exacerbated,
it was deepened, that fault
line was just wrenched open,
and you couldn't look away.
And in fact, I remember meeting in Bombay
a woman who used to live in the slums,
and she used to work as a domestic help
in the high rise
skyscrapers all around her.
And she said to me, she said,
"What kind of justice is this?
I'll say it in Hindi and
then I'll translate it.
She said,
(speaking in foreign language)
What kind of justice is this
that the virus came into India
traveling on an airplane,
and it's the poor person
who's walking on the roads?
Yeah, so I think that's what it was.
While it impacted everybody,
the way you experienced the pandemic
very much depended on
what class you were in,
what gender you were, what
cast you were, and yes,
sometimes what religion you were.
Because that TV channels did
not put people on the ground,
some of them decided
that this was the moment
to actually start communalizing
the COVID conversation.
The reason this happened
is one of the earliest mass
congregations that took place,
that was a super spread of
event, there's no doubt about it,
was by an orthodox Muslim
sect called Tablighi Jamaat.
And this was just at the
cusp of the restrictions
that were then subsequently placed
on all mass congregations
except of course election rallies.
That's a different debate.
And this undoubtedly was a congregation
that should not have taken
place, but once it did,
we actually had channels using
hashtags like CoronaJihad.
This was on a major television
channel, The Times Group.
And there was another network,
the India Today Network,
which represented the COVID dashboard
graphically in skull caps.
So they had silhouetted skull caps,
and they put the data
the count of COVID cases
that there was in a skull cap,
and you can get the reference of that.
So one every inequity was
deepened, wrenched open,
therefore for you to see
unless you were wanting to look away.
Two you actually had big
media not just look away,
but further sort of add to the toxicity
around this conversation.
So there was either an invisibilization
of what was happening to the poor,
and in the second we have
a complete invisibilization
of rural India, or there
was a kind of bigoted lens
through which this story was being told.
In the meantime, something very odd,
in India they say that everything you say
in its opposite is true.
And we are a very, very
paradoxical country,
and even on COVID by the way
one of the big mistakes that India made
was to order vaccines very late.
But when we finally got to it
because we have a history of
mass immunization programs
it's one of our big
public health successes,
we actually had boats, and drones,
and people walking through
jungles deliver vaccines.
And we became the second
country in the world
to cross the 2 billion
mark after China in July
of the previous year.
So what I'm saying is that
everything you say about India,
and its opposite is often true.
There has to be a granularity
in how we understand my country.
And the same thing
happened with the police.
In this lockdown the police
was first responders,
they were among the first responders.
So they were vulnerable, they were brave.
I met a policeman whose hand was cut off
for trying to sort of
enforce the lockdown,
but on the other hand,
the police was also weaponized
sometimes against the poorest citizen.
So what was happening
was that these people would try and leave,
the daily wage workers,
and they would be pushed back
from barricades by the police.
Some of them would fold
their hands and plead,
some of them would bribe their way,
some of them would just revolt and say,
okay, arrest me if you want to,
but I'm just breaking this barricade.
But a lot of people
would just keep walking
to the city barricade,
and we turn back from it,
and then have to walk dozens
of sort of miles again
to reach that barricade to be
turned back again and again.
And this was Seema who was
married to a scrap seller.
He used to just buy what in India
it's called kabadi, like your waste,
the newspapers that you finish reading
at the end of the day, tin
cans, basically garbage,
and repurpose it, right?
So he was a scrap seller.
She was married to him,
and they were trying to
get back to the village,
and she just collapsed in
tears, literally in my arms,
making me step back from
my old fashioned notions
of what is objectivity at this time.
I'd gone to J school,
and I'd been taught that
a journalist must have emotional distance
from the story that you're telling,
but in a situation like this,
how is that emotional distance possible?
Is it even desirable?
Then we come to the story of Punam.
Now, one of the things that happened,
and I'm sure Winnie,
and Charity's data may have
done some work on this is,
what are the assets that a
poor person has at this time?
Right?
So for most of India's poorest people
the one asset that they owned was a phone.
So when people didn't know what
to do and how to make ends,
sort of make ends meet, they
sold the only thing they had,
which was a phone.
So when I was telling the
story of these migrant workers,
and I could realize that
there was a class gap
between my audience, and the story,
and the class of the people I was telling.
So, now I had an audience
that was baking banana bread on Instagram,
talking about going to the Maldives,
talking about the COVID blue of the sky
that had suddenly been liberated
from Delhi's air pollution.
And I had to make this class of people
care about the poorest worker,
at a time when, let's face it,
they were also frightened, right?
So how were you going to
bridge this cast divide?
You had to come back to
compelling storytelling.
So I could have said,
millions of migrant workers are impacted,
and that would be true, but instead,
I chose to tell the story of
a man called Mukesh Mandal.
Mukesh Mandal was a house painter,
that's his photograph that
his wife Punam is holding up.
And he used to do the odd job
painting homes as they came
up on construction sites.
And like everybody else,
when the lockdown happened
his work came to a grinding halt,
and suddenly there was no
food to feed his children.
So he sold his phone, and he
sold his phone for 2000 rupees.
With those 2000 rupees,
he bought a table fan for 500
rupees because it was really,
really hot still in those months of Delhi,
or rather outskirts of
Delhi, he lived in Haryana,
and then he bought some
wheat, he bought some lentils,
he bought some grains, and
he took it to his wife,
who was relieved thinking
that at least this week
we won't go hungry, my
children won't go hungry.
But the next day Mukesh
felt a deep anxiety,
and he felt that he had
nothing else left to sell.
He could not see any visible
improvement in the future.
He didn't know what to do.
So he went to his wife, Punam,
and he asked to borrow
her what we call a dupatta, the scarf.
And took the dupatta,
he tied it to the bamboo
pole of the one room element,
and he took his own life.
And in my opinion this
was a starvation death.
It was the fear of hunger
that led him to die.
He had no visible source of income.
And in the lockdown
even the distribution of free Russians,
which were announced by all governments,
was extremely difficult
because the lockdown
became like a police enforced curfew
as opposed to a people led
protective measure, right?
So, but the district administration
that I went to meet subsequently said
that he was mentally unstable.
The family was made to
put they were illiterate,
and they were made to put their thumbprint
on a set of papers to say that
they didn't even understand
what they were signing,
and then the police could
quote that piece of paper,
and say that he was mentally unstable.
Meanwhile, the workers kept walking.
You would see images like this
that they with folded hands
stop a truck driver, say,
"Please let us get on."
And the truck driver in this case said,
"No, the police will come after me.
I can't give you a ride, not
even for a few kilometers."
And this went on for almost
60 days into the pandemic.
You had workers walking till this case
reached the Supreme Court,
and through forest, through nighttime
this became a parallel
crisis to the medical crisis
where already you had beds running short,
and you didn't have enough doctors.
And I remember one doctor telling me,
"I feel like I've been
sent to fight a nuclear war
with a latte, with a stick."
One such truck looked
like this at the back.
Initially, the cops wouldn't
let me see what was happening.
So I just had to fight with them,
and insist that I could get a look in.
And I saw, it looked like
every human trafficking movie
that I had seen.
It was just like, just these people,
like lumped together desperate to get out.
And I asked one of them that,
"Aren't you scared of getting COVID?"
Like that was a basic question, right?
Aren't you scared of getting COVID.
And he said, "Well, the
poverty will kill me
before the virus will."
And so he left.
One of the things that occurred to me
was when I saw these little sort of sacks
being carried by women
mostly on their head
as the men carry the children,
what do you carry when you leave,
and you don't know if you'll
make it to your destination,
and you don't know
whether you'll come back?
This was also a question
that partition researchers
have now looked at.
What did people carry?
I come from a kind of refugee family.
My parents, my father's side of the family
lived in undivided,
when India was undivided on
the Pakistan side in Sialkot.
And I grew up hearing these stories about
our family had this,
and our family had this,
and there was a piano in the
house, and there was this,
and there was this, and
then we came with nothing.
Now, of course, many
people came with nothing,
but even those who came with nothing,
and came as literally poor people
they went from being wealthy
to being poor overnight.
Everybody carried something, one thing,
one thing that meant something to them.
And so as I saw these people walk,
I wanted to know what did they carry?
And the answer was so
moving and humbling for me,
and this was their answer.
They carried in a plastic bucket,
so many of them that I met
their workman students.
And, of course, they
carried a couple of clothes,
and maybe a packet of biscuits,
and a blanket for their child,
but they carried their what in Hindi
is called their ozar, their tools.
And they said, "Maybe
we'll get work on the way.
Maybe something, maybe
there'll be somebody
who will give us work."
So even through this calamity,
even through this crisis,
these were people who were desperate.
They were not begging,
they were not saying, give us a dough.
They were just like, "We wanna
work, but there is no work."
And at that point
there was no sort of social security net
because they were like a displaced,
they were at that point an
internally displaced community.
So the idea that they
could get to a bank account
where a direct cash
transfer had taken place,
or through this sort of barricaded police
monitoring of movement,
they would even be able to
access a social welfare program
was an unrealistic sort of idea.
And so they carried their tools.
This was somewhere in
Telangana in the south,
and then there was this
nine year old child.
And I playfully asked him, I said,
"Oh, do you know what coronavirus is?"
By this time some public
transport had started
with the intervention
of the Supreme Court,
and he was standing in line
to take a bus back with
his father to his village.
And he said, "Of course
I know what it means."
And I said, "What does it mean?"
And he said, "It means I
don't get food to eat."
And that was a nine year
old child's understanding.
So, when we look at COVID,
and the pandemic as a medical
story, as a story of science,
as a story of doctors and drugs,
it is all of those things.
But for so many countries
it is also a story of power,
and access to resources and inequity.
But it's also a story
of hope, and compassion,
and kindness as I subsequently
discovered in my story,
in my journey, one of the odd
things that happened in India
was that there was either
too much centralization
or too little centralization.
So sometimes you just
had entire districts,
and it was left to the
district magistrate,
the local bureaucrat in the
area to take a decision.
And at other times, like
with the use of police
you had too much state or to little state.
The overarching presence of the police
was the state when you didn't need it.
And outside the hospitals,
when people would go from
hospital to hospital,
and there was not one person
either at the state level
or at the central level to
tell them where to go next.
And I witnessed people dying on the road
at the closed doors of hospital gates.
There was no state.
So when you needed the
state it went missing,
when you didn't want the state
there was too much of it.
Old people suffered in an,
I'm sure for those of you
who were here during the pandemic,
were any of you here during the pandemic
with families back home?
With families back home?
Okay, so you know what you
would've been going through
thinking about your parents
or your grandparents, right?
It's really strange, but
of all the stories I did
this one just cut across
classes and genres of viewers,
because I think it spoke
either to everybody's concern
about their parents
or it spoke to everybody's
guilt about their parents,
fear about growing old.
And this was Lilavat,
who was 70 years old,
and she was a widow.
She had come to meet her son in Bombay,
and then when the lockdown hit,
the son decided that he could not look
after his aging mother.
He didn't have any source of income,
and he was an alcoholic,
so he threw her out.
And because I was now
following the workers,
and by now trains had started running,
I met her sitting outside
railway station in Bombay,
and she'd had no food, no money.
And I said, "Where are you going?"
She said, "I don't know,
can you put me on a train?"
And I said, "But even
if I put you on a train,
where should I send you?"
And she said, "None of
my children will have me,
but can you send me to Delhi?
Because that's the city I know best
because I used to live there
when my husband was alive."
So I said, "But okay,
I'll send you to Delhi,
but what will you do?"
And she said, "I'll beg."
And I didn't know what to do.
All I could do was to tell her story,
and hope that somebody would take notice.
And that is what happened,
which is that when we released the story,
the railways then took
her into the waiting room,
They put her on a train,
and a politician in Delhi
actually took her in
as a temporary measure till her daughter
agreed to take her back.
But the story of Lilavat,
I mean, I have never seen,
like until this date three years later
somebody finds a story on Mojo Story.
They write to me saying, "Can
we financially help her?"
And it spoke to all of our,
I think, collective vulnerability.
This was Jyoti.
Jyoti got the attention of Ivanka Trump
for all the wrong reasons,
who decided to treat her trauma
as a sporting achievement
instead of the trauma that it was.
She was a 15 year old who
cycled with her father
at the back of the cycle,
1200 kilometers from Delhi to Bihar.
The reason that the father
couldn't ride the cycle
is because he just had a knee
surgery, so he couldn't pedal.
The cycle was luxury most
other people were walking,
and those shoes feted by the
world as this sort of champion.
And she was given many free cycles,
like what was she gonna
do with those cycles?
She kept saying, and I met her twice,
and she kept saying all
I want to do is study.
And that is literally my only dream,
and I cried every night.
We would stay at the gas stations,
the petrol pumps on the highway.
I was a young girl.
That was a family later,
is when the few happy
endings of this story.
she became such a global star
that her house became the first
brick house in her village
because people did offer
to financially support her.
There's now a movie being made on her.
But again, I will say
that there was a kind of
romancing of this story,
a romanticization of the story.
No 15 year old girls should
have to cycle back home
through a pandemic with her father
at the back of the cycle
through a lockdown.
She should never have had to do that.
And there was a great romanticism.
I met her in her village
in Bihar, and she said,
"I've got 15 cycles, would
you like to try one?"
So we went to a cycle, right?
She took me to her school and she said,
"All I want to do is study."
One of the other things
that we don't talk about,
and I really felt strongly
about this during the pandemic
is what happened to other
people who were ill?
Other illnesses did not stop.
And so whether it was kidney disease,
whether it was cancer,
whether it was little
children falling ill,
needing a heart surgery,
we saw this happening.
We saw poor people in particular
come to the sort of gates
of public health hospitals
because that's all they could afford.
Those hospitals were taken over,
and become totally COVID hospitals.
And so suddenly you had
people bearing their children.
These were five girls whose
father died from tuberculosis.
He was a tea vendor.
This was a cancer patient
I met outside one of the hospitals,
and he was just told by the guard,
"Now you go to the next hospital."
He was like, "What's the next hospital?"
And no one could tell him where to go.
So he was just this lonely man
I just met outside
one of the public health
hospitals in Delhi,
and he was just walking.
Those are the five girls
who lost their father to tuberculosis.
Now, this story,
I was talking about the
paradox of the police
being both vulnerable, brave frontliners,
and also weaponized against
the most vulnerable citizens.
This was Manoj.
He used to ride rickshaw,
an electronic richshaw.
And because there was no food,
he decided that he wanted to go,
and buy some vegetables
from the wholesale market.
So he wandered outside
of the permissible area
that was allowed in the lockdown,
and the police got hold of him,
they beat him, and his arm was fractured.
They beat him, and they
deposited him outside a hospital,
which wouldn't take him in.
And because truth is so much
more dramatic than fiction,
this image to me was the most ironic image
because I found him leaning
against this police barricade,
beaten by the police,
left by the police outside this hospital,
which wouldn't take him in.
And what did he do? He just
went out to buy vegetables.
These were workers who
died in a road accident.
Remember they were taking
lifts where they could,
and their bodies were
shoved into plastic packets,
and sent back home on ice slabs,
the only surviving worker of this accident
said that we are being
treated worse than insects.
Those are scenes from that accident side.
And this by the time trains were opening,
it started with freight trains,
good trains that were
carrying essential supplies.
Tribal workers decided,
they came from a very, very remote village
in the heartland of
India in Madhya Pradesh,
and according to me
sometimes a single image
tells you the whole story of a pandemic.
And the image I'm going
to show you next to me
is I think probably
the most stirring image
I have seen out of the pandemic.
These were men who, and they were all men,
they were walking home
hundreds of kilometers
like everybody else,
and they decided to sleep
on the rail tracks for two reasons.
They thought there are no passenger trains
because there were no passenger trains.
And two, they thought they
could hide from the police
who might send them back,
but as they laid there
at 4:00 in the morning,
a good strain that was
carrying supplies came,
and ran over them.
All 18 of them died.
And this is all that remained of them.
A little packet of roti, a
bread that they'd packed.
Like I said food was scarce.
Even if you had money there was no shops,
no harbors, no roadside sort
of properties that were open,
and this was what remained of them.
And I went to their village.
It was literally on my
100 day on the road,
I went to their village,
and it was the toughest place to get to.
I said, "This is someone
who has covered war,
and riots and calamity."
That it was such a remote village
that it took me 18 hours by road,
and then another few hours on foot
to get to where they came from.
And nobody had thought,
who were these people
who died on the rail tracks?
What was the name of the village?
What were their names?
And I met their families.
And like this, we moved
into the second wave.
And in the second wave we learned
a lot from the first wave,
we did not shut public transport.
We learned that hospitals
should not be converted
into COVID only hospitals
because there are people dying
from other ailments that also
need medical intervention.
But this was a pregnant, a new mother,
I beg your pardon,
who just gave birth to a one day old baby.
And she had COVID, she
had no hospital to go to.
Now this became the crisis, right?
Now you couldn't get a bed in hospital,
you just couldn't get a bed in hospital.
And if you could get a bed in hospital,
you couldn't get oxygen.
And I met people who were made to sign
what I have called
modern day death warrants
because they were just made
to sign waivers saying,
and it is in the
hospital's fault, frankly,
because they didn't have the oxygen.
They were made to sign warrants saying
that if your loved one dies
from a shortage of oxygen,
you will not sue the hospital, right?
I saw something I never
thought I would see in my life.
Gurdwaras which are
Sikh places of worship
normally have a what's called a langar,
which is a free meal for
the very poor, right?
(speaking in foreign language)
I mean, some of you would
be familiar with the langar.
Gurdwaras in India
started oxygen langars.
Now, this is also about the hope,
and the compassion that one saw
where governments were
missing people stepped in.
Social media for once
became a mechanism for good.
People would say, do you know
someone who can supply oxygen?
Do you know someone who can
give me so and so supply,
and Gurudwaras started what
was called oxygen langars.
And you would see scenes like this
where there would be
giant oxygen cylinders
placed on the road.
Somebody could drive in
or come on a rickshaw,
poor, rich, it didn't matter.
You were allowed to have access
to a single oxygen cylinder
for half an hour then you had to move on,
and make room for the next person.
It was like the McDonald's of oxygen.
It was like a drive through.
And it feels almost like weird now
for me to say it like this,
but this is what it was.
It was a drive through oxygen langar.
In the meantime, people started
taking cardboard strips.
I actually met a family that
slept on cardboard strips
on the floor of this
was a Bombay Hospital.
These were the images from
our cremation grounds,
our graveyards, our hospitals,
just absolute devastation.
And now we come to this image
which became a major, major,
major fault line in India's
internal discussions.
How many people have died from COVID?
We started this conversation
by saying that numbers
didn't tell the full story.
You needed to know the
people behind the numbers.
The unfortunate dimension to this
is we don't even know the numbers, right?
The epidemiologists all
vary in their estimation.
The World Health Organization
says 10 times more people
have died in India than
the official count.
In the middle of all of this,
I remember this day well,
it was one day before my father died.
My father died from COVID, and
it was very strange for me.
We were in the second wave by now.
This had been my whole life,
and I literally became the
story I had been reporting.
Obviously, [36:47] with all the caveats
that I came from privilege.
When my father couldn't
get a hospital bed,
I was able to call a doctor.
I was able to say, "Please
get him a hospital bed."
The doctor agreed, but the
hospital was an hour away.
And there was no ambulance
available at that time.
And I made a mistake that
continues to haunt me,
that we, my sister and I,
got what was called a private agency.
And they said, it's a private ambulance,
but when the so-called ambulance arrived
it was a broken down van, like
a really old ramshackled van.
It had a hard bench at the
back, it had a kind of rusty,
giant oxygen cylinder lying on the floor.
And he didn't even have a mask.
There was only a driver,
there were no paramedics.
And I had to make a split second decision,
do I send this guy away?
Do I just wait for the hospital ambulance?
And I made the decision
to jump on the front seat,
and go with my father
all the while driving
through a snarl of traffic
that had again been created
by police barricades
who were trying to enforce a lockdown.
Anyway, there was a whole
mile long of other daughters
possibly in ambulances with their fathers,
and here we go to this hospital.
And by the time we reached the hospital
my father was supposed to be
admitted to a general room,
and the doctors on emergency
duty, they checked his oxygen,
and they found that the
cylinder hadn't worked
as it was meant to.
So, his oxygen levels had plummeted,
and he had to be admitted to an ICU.
There was no ICU bed.
And literally I had spent a year
and a half telling this
story about other people,
people outside hospitals,
people not able to get
a bed, people desperate.
I now became that desperate person.
Please, I need an ICU bed.
We got the ICU bed,
but it was the last time
that I saw him alive.
And five days later when he died,
we had to cremate him near the hospital
because the hospital was
technically in another state,
and it would've needed police permission
to bring him back home.
So we couldn't bring him back home.
And at the cremation ground
there was no space to cremate him.
So we actually had to
call the police to say
that can you please help
us cremate our father?
And that evening I tested
positive for COVID.
So it was very surreal,
but I remember this image
because it was the evening
before I took my father to hospital,
and it was a cremation ground
where this was the image.
And the caretaker of the
cremation ground told me
that the official number from the city
that week had been 30, but he'd
handled 300 bodies in a day.
And so it became my kind of
mission after I got better.
It was also the only way
I knew how to deal with loss and grief,
that I was going to change the story
of the uncounted COVID deaths,
because I felt that, I mean,
we had criticized the media ourselves
saying people can't just be numbers.
And now we were saying
they weren't even numbers,
but when we had these
images, and some of us did,
we were called vultures by trolls
who said that we were
feasting off the dead,
and we were sort of why were
we showing these images?
And look at the American press
because it never does
a story on mass graves.
This is not true.
I personally pulled out several stories
from the front pages of the
post to The New York Times
that had actually done similar stories
on uncounted COVID deaths
here in the United States of America.
So it's not that this did not happen here,
but then this was another cremation ground
where literally bodies were
lying on the floor like this
because there was just no
place to actually cremate them.
This is drone footage of
the banks of the Ganga.
So before I show you the next few visuals,
I just want you to understand
what was happening.
Remember we spoke in the beginning
of invisibilization by the media,
of a number of things that were happening.
By the time the second wave happened,
if in the first wave
the daily wage workers
had been invisibilized
by the second wave,
rural India did not
figure in COVID reporting,
it just didn't figure in COVID reporting.
Now, what was happening
in the villages of India
is that people were not testing,
either they were not testing
because there were stigma
or they were not testing
because there was no access to testing,
or if they were testing
they didn't know what to do next
because hospitals weren't
close by enough to access.
So what started happening is that
if you would go to villages,
you would find that the
Panchayat would tell you
the local sort of village
governance module would tell you
that in these last two months we have seen
a surge in the number of
people dying from fever, and
(speaks in foreign language)
as it called cough and
cold and breathlessness,
which would, of course,
symptoms of this respiratory disorder
that we understood COVID to be.
But had they been tested, no.
And because they hadn't been tested,
they would never be
counted among the dead.
And because rural India was
completely invisibilized,
nobody was documenting these.
So, you were not counted
if you died at home,
you were not counted if you
did not get an RT-PCR Test.
I have met people who spent
their days in an ambulance
trying to get tested,
and couldn't get tested,
and then died in the ambulance.
That would not be
counted as a COVID death.
And you were not counted as dead
if you died from shortage of oxygen,
which scores of people dead
as oxygen just ran out in the ICUs.
And if your death certificate
did not list COVID
as the cause of death,
and there were states where
the local administration
was instructed that you don't
get into the cause of death,
let the hospital decide.
The hospital would say,
oh, oxygen ran short,
but I'm not gonna give
that as the cause of death.
Cause of death was
cardiac disorder, right?
So through the cracks of officialdom,
the way the system was set up,
the fact that many people
couldn't get a death certificate,
the fact that the cause of death
became something that the administration,
and private hospitals
started bombing off to one another.
And again, remember if
you think of Mukesh Mandal
who had sold his phone,
now you had objectively
poor people who sold
again everything they own,
maybe a piece of jewelry,
maybe a piece of land
in the belief that a private
hospital would save lives.
They thought, okay,
public health system
is totally overridden,
maybe the private hospitals will.
And that in so many of
these private hospitals
the oxygen ran shot.
In the meantime, there was
some family that was so poor
that they did not even
have wood to burn the dead.
So for a combination of these reasons,
we started seeing this very
tragic phenomena in North India,
in parts of North India,
where bodies were thrown into rivers
or left in the river
banks in the dead of night
with just what is called
the ramnami cloth,
which is a sacred cloth for Hindus.
And this is the kind of
scene that you would see
as you travel down the banks of the river,
but this became a really,
really politicized conversation.
And by 2021,
I started to feel a kind of
fury at everything I was seeing.
And I'm a political junkie.
I live for elections.
I live to cover elections.
But at that time, it seemed
to me to be so, I don't know,
immortal, and egregious that
elections were being held
while this is what I was
finding on the banks,
that elections were being held
while schools were closed, right?
That government employees
who were teachers
in government schools were forcibly sent
on election duty for local elections.
And more than 1000 of
them died from COVID.
These were all lower income
families who were employed.
A pregnant woman was among them.
So I was for the first
time in my democracy
that I'm otherwise proud of,
I was really offended by the
fact that these elections
were being held, and I decided
to not cover the elections.
Maybe it made a difference to nobody,
but at my level boycotted,
and I don't really believe
in boycott, but I was like,
I'm not gonna cover these elections.
These elections shouldn't be held.
So there was again in
this media disconnect
because by now the media
had just turned away
from all of this, and was
back on the elections.
And the elections were the headlines.
These were not the headlines, right?
And this is what was happening
on the banks of our river.
Many of these places were
not reachable by road.
You had to get onto a
motorcycle, you had to walk,
you had to take a boat down the Ganga.
And finally, we said in the beginning that
every existing inequity
was exacerbated by COVID.
Among the things I discovered
was what happened to cast groups
whose traditional occupation
was to wash the bodies of the dead.
And these cast groups
existed even within Muslims.
So this was Hyderabad
where I met a man who said,
"I'm a body washer."
That was his professional occupation.
He actually had an ID card that said this.
And nobody was willing to
come near these families.
And in Varanasi where Hindus
among Hindus Dalits
traditionally washed the body,
and were washing COVID bodies
before they were taken to the pyre.
I remember what one of them said,
and this happened in front of me.
I was walking with him in
front of a cremation ground,
and there was a shopkeeper and he said,
"Get away from here."
He said to this young man
who's washing everybody's bodies
before they they were lit.
And he said, "Look at this.
We are doing what families want,
but we are still treated like this."
And now doubly so because we are washing
the bodies of the COVID death.
So I guess in effect,
there were things of
course that were uplifting.
They were for the poison that
we saw on television channels.
I met community groups where
Hindus, and Muslims buried,
and cremated each other's
sort of each other's dead.
I met a man called Abdul
Malbar in Surat in Gujarat
where he had one ambulance
and the ambulance said,
"Funerals for lonely humans."
And his one purpose in life was to go,
and according to your faith
perform the last rites.
So in his sort of closet sized office,
he had Ganga jar,
which is a sacred water
of the river Ganga,
but he also had namaz mats.
In the Housing Societies in Surat,
I met women who were homemakers who said,
"We don't know how to help,
but maybe we can cook five
more rotis than we do,
and every day we cook these rotis."
We saw people rally together
and behind each other
help perfect strangers.
And when we finally got our act together
in terms of getting the vaccines out,
as I said in the beginning, we did well,
we had very minimal vaccine hesitancy
compared to the kind of
politics you see around it here.
Once we learned from our
mistakes, we learned,
but by then so many people
had paid a very, very costly price.
And I think, I'll just end by saying like,
I know it's difficult to remember COVID.
I know that people don't want
to remember it, but again,
I'll drop part with
partition where Ashis Nandy,
who's one of India's best sociologists,
he did this project called
Memory and Partition.
And one of the things he argued was that
whenever something cataclysmic happens
in the life of a people,
or in the life of a nation
like the partition of India,
the instinct is to put a lid
on it, and to bury the memory.
And the moment you bury a memory,
there is a kind of
schizophrenia that develops,
and that has developed as we
see between India and Pakistan.
And COVID is something similar.
I think we are desperate to forget.
I can understand that,
I live nothing else for two years plus.
I get the whole need to move on.
But I think if we don't pause to think,
okay, what did it teach
us about ourselves?
What did it teach us
about our relationships?
What did it teach us about society,
about the organization of
power, about, I don't know,
access to resources?
What should policy be going forward?
Why aren't these things
that people vote on?
The quality of air, the
quality of healthcare.
There's so much to think about here?
And for me personally I call
reporting the Kargil War in '99.
My first masterclass in
life, I was 26 and a half,
I covered COVID in my 40s.
And it really literally was
a second masterclass in life.
It made me reexamine every assumption
of what I understood to be
the role of a journalist,
what I understood to be my role,
what I understood to be
the hierarchy of news,
what I understood about TV channels
about the people of India.
And I think those discussions continue.
Many things don't have certitude,
but as long as one can at least
begin asking the questions
now with the benefit of some distance,
I think that will be the
lesson we need to take away,
otherwise it may not be COVID,
it'll be something else tomorrow,
and our fault clients will
be wrenched open once again.
So I'll just stop there.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Barkha.
That was all absorbing
and also heart wrenching,
and I think I speak for everyone,
we're sorry for your loss
as well of your father
through all this,
but thank you for sharing that,
and for taking that journey
over those two years as well.
I think you did a huge
service for all of us
to really understand what has happened.
I'm going to turn right now,
and I hope that this works
if I just move ahead with the slides, yes.
To some research insights.
So I'm going to try to put some data
to some of the faces that you showed us.
And I want to turn to the issue of gender.
And I know we don't have a lot of time,
so I'm going to ask two questions,
and then I think we can
open it up for the audience,
and the people online as well,
so we make sure we can
have time with them.
So in July when we were together,
we talked a little bit
about some of the surveys
that we've conducted
through inclusion economics.
So that's, lemme come a
little closer, thanks,
that's with Rohini here, Jenna Allard,
who's in the audience, myself,
Yusuf Neggers, Simone Schaner,
and then Maulik Jagnani here
with other universities.
So when COVID hit, we
decided what can we do?
I think like many
people, we were thinking,
what can we do to help, right?
And what we knew we could
do is we can collect data,
and at least try to document,
and then share information about
the migrants in particular,
but just anyone that we
could collect data on
to understand what was
happening through this crisis.
And we worked with government
partners and they said,
"We don't really understand
what's happening,
so please do help us,
help us understand in
particular these migrants
that are leaving cities."
And so the migrants as
they were returning back
to their home states
they were intercepted,
and people would collect their details,
and then we use that information
to call these individuals.
And ultimately what we did
is we went back to a
core group of migrants
about four different times to understand
how well they were doing
through the pandemic.
So just to kind of show you,
we surveyed them over a 15 month period.
We reached out to them
four different times,
and had 1,780 individuals
that returned to Bihar,
and Chhattisgarh to just understand
what had happened to them.
And what came out from this in particular
was a real gender gap,
and gender disparities
in terms of being able to
return to life as usual,
particularly for those who had
worked prior to the pandemic.
So I'm gonna focus in
on the group of migrants
who are already working.
So these were, many
women in India don't work
of course outside the home,
but we're only focusing on men,
and women who worked
prior to the pandemic.
And what I'll show you
is we have information,
sorry, it's gonna be
hard for you to see here,
but at the beginning of the pandemic
we're looking at all women
who were working about four,
and five were working in
some sort of unskilled labor,
and we surveyed them
through what we called recovery
phase one, and phase two,
and then in COVID phase two.
And what we saw is that these women
ended up going from skilled labor
often into unskilled labor
or more commonly agricultural jobs
or just dropping outta
the labor force entirely.
And that persisted all
the way through the end
of the second phase of COVID
where half of the women that we spoke with
who had previously been
employed in urban areas,
they were no longer employed.
Many of these women were stuck
back at home in the villages,
and could not actually return.
If we compare it to the figure for men
what we see here is about half of the men
were in skilled labor, and then
as the pandemic hit, again,
agriculture absorbed lots of migrants,
and was able to help them
especially through that first wave,
and by the end, and by the second wave
about a third of the men were unemployed
even during this downturn,
but it didn't really compare well
to what was going on for women.
And as I mentioned, sorry,
this is probably too much
information on one side,
but essentially women
were stuck in rural areas.
The ones that were
remaining in rural areas
had a much more difficult time
actually finding work in particular.
And this was 15 months
after the pandemic began,
and that's what we see.
We also see that women failed
to recover their earnings
even prior to the pandemic,
of course, they were earning
less money than men on average,
but if we look at what happened to them,
sorry for the blurriness at the bottom,
I'm not sure why that is.
If we look at their recovery,
essentially men were able to recover
very close to the level that they earned
prior to the pandemic,
but these women, again,
were not able to do that.
And then finally, these women too,
particularly the ones that were
kind of stuck in rural areas
15 months after the pandemic began
were reporting that they were
likely to reduce consumption,
and more so than kind of other men,
and or men, and those who had
gone into urban areas as well.
So, all that to say,
just wanted to show you some
of what we had gathered,
and I'd love to hear your
perspective in particular
on what happened to women
through the pandemic,
and what you saw through that gender lens.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that as you said
(indistinct) inequity amplified,
and that is what happened
to women as well.
And what I remember is during
the pandemic pregnant women
really struggling to get
access to any healthcare,
that is my first memory of COVID.
Like you actually had to
have doctors going to slums
or do these virtual calls,
and you would meet these
pregnant women on the streets.
When we spoke about the other
people who needed healthcare.
So that is my first memory,
think of all these pregnant women.
Secondly, in India at least,
I don't know how it was here,
pregnant women got
access to vaccines last.
The debate just carried on over
whether it was safe, not safe.
And finally it was like a
group of sort of doctors
that led the demand, and said
that this must must happen.
But what happened inside homes
is in fact very, very distressing.
We had a distinct spike
in the reported cases of domestic abuse.
We don't even know right now
what the unreported
cases may have been like.
The government run child helpline
was deluged with calls from children,
and girls mostly saying that we do not,
we are being forced
into underage marriage.
I went to investigate one of these trends,
and I ended up in a village in Rajasthan
where I basically found that
what was happening was that
because we had among the longest
physical school lockdowns in the world
vast number of girls were
just out of the classroom.
If a family had one internet device
then if there was a boy
it was given to the boy.
And so you had all of these
girls who had nothing to do,
and then their families would tell them
that since you're doing nothing,
you should go and get married.
And one of the saddest things I ever heard
was one of the activists
who was working with these girls told me
that in some cases it's the mothers
who are pushing for these girls
to go to the so-called
infant husband's village
because with the man at home
if he turned abusive or violent
or in some cases forced
sex on his partner,
and remember these are
homes we're talking about
in very enclosed tiny spaces,
the mothers didn't think their
daughters were safe at all.
And they actually thought
that the daughters
may be safer if...
So, some did it because what you're doing?
Go, get married.
Some did it because they thought
that they were actually creating distance
between their girls in an abusive house.
Of course, like with
everything else in India,
these girls answered it by
forming a football team.
It was just an incredible story.
They formed a football team,
and every time the
village elders would say,
"What are you doing?"
They say we play football.
And then they actually became
state level football players,
but not every village had that
kind of sort of happy ending.
And let's not pretend that
this happened only to the poor.
We had, I think, if I'm not wrong,
please you guys are the
experts, at some point
I think the female labor force
participation number hit 9%
at one point in the pandemic.
And basically what was happening
was that even in the paleo class,
people like us with partners at home,
with children at home this work from home
today sounds like a concept
which is meant to make your life easier.
But if you're a woman in India,
and there is no equality at home,
there's no degenerating of the workspace,
of the home space, I beg your
pardon, of the roles at home,
of whose job it is to put
the food on the table,
and whose job it is to
get the children dressed,
also do your job, right?
That burden fell (indistinct) on women,
and women just stopped walking.
Women just said, "We can't do this."
So, everything from vaccine access
to access to healthcare for pregnant women
to domestic violence to underage marriages
to having to leave your work.
This was a very, very,
very gendered experience.
And the other thing is that women,
at least in our cultural context,
are so conditioned to be all sacrificing.
There is so much romance
around this sacrificing woman
that you don't hear a lot of these stories
till you go out to seek them.
The women don't come forward to complain
because they have over decades
of cultural conditioning
internalized that if there's
one roti in the house,
my child and my husband will eat it first.
So I haven't even begun
to get into sort of the
malnourishment data,
or the maternal mortality
data that would've emerged
in these years,
but anecdotally this is
what I saw happening.
I saw women leaving work
in educated upper middle
classrooms and literally,
I mean I know women when I
literally was like, don't do it.
You'll regret it.
It'll be tough to get back.
It'll be just kind of
take the anxiety of it.
So at every layer you saw
women experiencing the pandemic
in a very, very different way.
- Definitely resonates.
Okay, so I have one last question for you.
Thank you for that.
And then we can open
it up to the audience,
and people online too.
And that is you referenced,
I think we're probably the group of people
that if we were in India,
we were baking banana bread,
and maybe sending some money to someone
or in the U.S. making sourdough bread
or whatever it was,
and you told this story
about this young boy,
what does corona mean?
What is corona? It was,
it means that I'm hungry.
So, COVID's not the last
shock we're all going to face.
And I think, you said you
want us to learn from this,
so, just practically
speaking, what can we do?
How can we help consider
those that are completely invisibilized,
and marginalized in the day to day?
Yeah.
- I mean, to be completely honest
if I weren't a journalist,
I would've also been
at home with the same,
I come from the same class,
I come from privilege.
So I may self-identify as middle class,
but that is more cultural value
than an economic condition.
And so I don't want to be,
I wasn't meaning to be holier
than thou or being judgy.
I was just saying that
was the fact of life
that upper middle class Indians
were distraught with anxiety,
and they were dealing with it
by extending themselves
with all kinds of new
sort of cooking skills or whatever.
And I would've done the same
had I've been sitting at home
and not been among the people.
I basically think we have to ask more
of our political class and our media.
As people on this side,
you have to ask more of it.
You see right now what really scares me
is that there is a growing
disconnect between people
and politics and people and media.
And I think a lot of people,
like I think (indistinct) had this study
where they spoke about
this new genre of people
who are news avoiders,
basically like growing number of people
now feel there's no point
by engaging with journalism because my,
firstly, it's all bad news.
I don't wanna feel bad or
I don't wanna be triggered
or what can I do about it
anyway, so you know what?
It's just better that I don't know it.
And I have friends like this,
we are friends who at the
end of like a day from hell,
I'll go back and say,
don't you do this happened?
And they'll be like, what?
And in some ways I'm grateful for them
because they keep me real,
and there's another dimension to my life.
It's the other level.
It's instructive to me that
there is just such a gap
that nobody today actually feels that
what the media shows you is
something that impacts you.
The media is just
something other people do.
It's just some something
that journalists do.
How does it impact your life, right?
So I think till we start
asking more of our journalists,
and more of our governments
everywhere in the world,
I mean it really bothers me.
As a person who lives in Delhi
who has become asthmatic
in her 40s, that I am not,
I live in a city where people don't vote
on the basis of what
the quality of air is.
That we as women don't vote on the basis
of whom might have a policy
that is more sort of forward thinking
when it comes to women, right?
And of course people are many things.
We're not just women or
citizens of Delhi or just in,
we are many different things and politics,
elections are won, and lost
on a multiple set of issues.
But what can we do is to not,
I think the biggest thing we
can do is to not disengage.
I just feel that there
is such a disengagement.
It is so deep between
people, and politics,
and people in media that I really believe
that the next calamity, and
there will be a next calamity.
I mean, would we have globally
learned anything from it?
I remember I was looking
at the U.S. from Delhi,
and I was like, how can you not have any,
like how can there be such
tolerance for anti-vaccers?
How self-indulgent is it that
people are dying in my country
because they can't get access
to vaccines in the first stage
when the government
hadn't purchased enough,
and there are vaccines just going waste
in other parts of the world, right?
But who's engaged? Who's making a noise?
And the second thing is,
and I really believe
this is a storyteller,
that you have to have a way to communicate
outside of your echo chamber.
There is no purpose in
my saying this to people
who already think like me,
so then what is we achieved?
And if it takes some
academic to get onto TikTok,
if it takes me to learn
how to do a 30 second video
instead of 40 minute talk, I
have to learn how to do it.
We just have to get off our
preachy little high horses,
and figure out a language
that actually speaks
to people who are outside of how we think.
And I think the collapse of conversation
across differences of opinion in America,
in India this is costly to framing policy
because policy is for all,
policy exists irrespective
of which party you vote,
and therefore there has to be some way
of finding consensus on policy.
And with the polarization
in media, in politics,
I really worry about finding
that consensus for policy.
- Yeah, likewise.
I definitely think that's an issue here.
I know people have,
I don't know if there's researchers
that some story was even just hearing
about family conversations,
we even cartel those, and be
self censor I think a lot,
and also disengage.
Shall we go ahead with some
questions from the audience
or Zara you kind of lead where we start.
So does anyone here have questions?
I think if you do go
ahead and raise your hand,
and we've got a few from
the audience online as well.
- Thank you first of all for
your time for coming here.
I follow you, your channel on
YouTube and also on Facebook.
So talking about holding
politicians accountable.
I wholeheartedly agree with you on this.
So I grew up in Kolkata,
and I am very much in touch with
everything that's going on in India,
and especially in Bengal.
So I begin my day with Andy TV and CNN,
and I can confirm that
it's not the ideal way
to start my day because it makes me angry.
So last week I called while I
was watching the Indian news,
I called the ABP Network.
Kolkata based, because
a politician who I know
had very humble beginnings,
and really became Uber wealthy
in a few years as it happens.
And he had an eye issue
that was bothering him,
and like all politicians,
India wasn't good enough.
So he flew to Johns Hopkins
to get his eye tested,
and apparently he's also going to be back
for a follow up appointment,
and I can barely make it to New York City
for my follow up appointments.
I asked the person who
took the call, I said,
"My complaint is not to
you not directed at you,
but can you please ask your journalists
to raise this question
that when the public health infrastructure
is barely existent, how on earth
do these people shamelessly
fly all the way to the
U.S. for a eye exam?
And why on the journalists
asking these questions?"
And his answer was, "Ma'am you
know their hands are tied."
And that is my request
to you first of all,
thank you for choosing
independent journalism.
I think it is very, very
important to keep democracy alive.
And if you can address this
issue, and when you go back,
and just bring some
awareness around this that...
- Yeah, no thank you,
and I'll follow this up,
but it's kind of similar in India,
we're having this whole
debate around language,
I don't know how many of
you have been following it,
and a recent sort of parliamentary
panel recommended that,
and parts of it has support
an emphasis on regional languages
on the fact that people should know Hindi,
and also if you're in Tamil Nadu, Tamil,
and just whatever your own language is,
but the operative part
of it is this attempt
to remove the privacy of English
because it's a colonial language.
And I just think that if
we were to just pull out
how many people,
how many of our political class
send their children to
English medium schools,
I think that the hypocrisy of
that would be evident to see.
So I think it's similar.
I think those who can get
treatment outside of India,
in politics, in society,
even in media board,
and I think, I mean
there's definitely a story
if it's being done on taxpayers money,
but otherwise it's a story
of double speak, right?
Where you encourage the poor
to say you must get treated at home,
but you fly abroad yourself.
But again you follow the news,
but I'm telling you the real crisis is,
one, people don't follow the news,
two, when they follow the news,
they only follow the news
that they already agree with.
So they never think that there's a reality
outside of the news they follow,
and they're so shocked, and so judgemental
when they see that news,
but that's your fellow
citizens who think differently.
And I think the real crisis is, for me,
is that if you can't create a consensus
on certain basic universal
values in public policy,
in public health policy,
a bureaucrat is meant to execute
like the migrant workers,
it shouldn't matter whether
you vote BJP Congress,
Tranemo, TRS, it shouldn't matter.
It cannot matter at this time.
And that ideological battles today
obstruct partnerships in policy making
is something that deeply concerns me
because honestly people
who work in this space
have to work with all governments.
They can't afford to bring
their political leanings
to being public policy
or public health experts.
A doctor who heads all
their medical institute
is not going to say, I vote
this way, so I will now not,
you know what I mean.
So, when we talk about news consumption,
I mean I will follow
up what you've told me,
but I will briefly also
say that please do engage
with news outside of the news
that you already agree with.
- [Audience Member] I
do. I watch news here.
- And it's important.
Honestly, it's important.
- [Audience Member] It's
important to know that.
- Yeah, it is.
(indistinct)
- I think there's a
couple of questions here.
- [Audience Member] I
can just (indistinct).
- Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Thanks you, Barkha,
for coming once again.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] I just had a question.
You touched upon education a little bit.
- [Audience Member] Here is a mic.
- [Audience Member] Give him a microphone.
- Thank you.
You touched about the pandemic
like education during pandemic,
and how education was
one of the last things
that were opened up in India when U.S.
and UK probably did it like
six, seven months before.
So as you were traveling
particularly in 2021,
did you see people on the
ground talking about it?
Did you see any concerns
about educational institutes being closed,
and particularly with the
birth of mobile phones
or laptops so that they
can attend virtual classes?
What did you see on the ground about?
- Oh, I saw in particular
lower income groups
people desperate for schools
to reopen, desperate.
Like there was a kind of desperation,
and the one thing that actually
there was a kind of class
unison was please open schools,
obviously for the poor, as I said,
with the child marriages and so on,
the costs were different.
But I think you now have enough data
on the fact that children's
cognitive skills, social skills,
emotional skills, learning skills,
all of them have been really
sort of egregiously hit
in the last two years.
The other thing I saw was poor families
were really dipping into savings
to pay the fees of private schools.
And those fees didn't automatically stop.
So what was really happening
was this big crisis
where incomes had halted,
but the school fees didn't have to be paid
otherwise you would lose
your spot in the school.
And among the more,
it just came to me
that one of the most
tragic stories I reported
was a young girl who was the daughter
of an auto rickshaw driver from Hyderabad,
and he had put together everything he had,
sold the only piece of land.
He had two daughters,
and he couldn't afford
to educate them both.
So he had to take this decision
that I will invest my savings in the one
who seems to show more scholarly promise.
So he managed to get her
into Lady Shri Ram College,
which is a premier college in Delhi.
And when it was announced
that classes had to go online,
she was so distraught because
she didn't have a laptop,
and she took her whole life.
And so I think we underestimate
what education means,
especially to those, I mean,
I know that there were kids
who had to be pulled out of school
because their parents had lost their job,
and they suddenly couldn't
afford to pay the fees.
Fees was a major issue.
So this is again an
example of a disconnect.
This is what people cared about,
but this was not on the media.
It was just not on the media.
And everywhere people would
be like, can you please,
like we are just desperate for women
who wanted to go back to work
to those hours in the day
where your children went to school
was also about your space to do something
or for poorer families, the
absence of a midday meal scheme,
hot one cooked meal.
So, we have to join the dots
between all of these things.
So I picked up a lot of
this, but it was unmovable.
You could not move
policy across government.
You could not, and by
the way in many cases
parents of privileged classes,
some were very in favor of opening,
some were very opposed to it.
And in the absence of that
consensus mean no schools open.
- [Zara] Okay, we have an online question,
and this may be our last question
'cause we're shorter on time.
So the question is,
can you comment on the similarities,
and differences between
covering COVID and covering war?
- Oh, that's a great question.
And I actually, if I
had to bookend my life,
not that I plan to retire,
but if I had to bookend
my life in journalism
it would be from Kargil to COVID.
Both were the toughest
stories I've ever reported.
Both transformed me personally.
When I went to cover war,
I had to really fight as a woman
to be allowed to the War front.
There were no mobile phones at that time.
There was no broadcast living,
capacity to broadcast live.
We would still film on tape.
We would walk kilometers in the mountains
to find chopper pilots who
could take our tapes back.
It was obviously life
and death, very risky.
And yet again, my attempt
there was to humanize,
and understand the psychology
of the Indian soldier
who was really 24, 25 years old.
And I wanted to understand
what a young man,
they were all men then,
infantry continues to
be all men even today,
what a young man thinks
when he's walking into possible death.
How does courage and
vulnerability coexist?
So it was kind of very
transforming for me personally.
And among the toughest, scariest,
riskier stories I had ever
done till it came to COVID.
Where too, there was so much unknown.
And in Kargil at least you knew
that there were Pakistani intruders
sitting on the Indian mountain peaks,
and they were going to bomb you,
and you had to hide when the bomb came,
and you had to take cover.
And I didn't always know what to do,
I was very young, but I
learned certain things.
I had a female producer with me
when we were traveling
across India for COVID.
And I don't notice because
I've done this for so long
that there are no bathrooms
for women along the way.
Like I'm just picking up something small
where we're talking about
the gendered experience,
and gender experience of reporting.
So men can take a leak
wherever they want to,
but there's nothing, and
she was just modified.
And because I had been trained in this,
I had done this in Kargil,
there were no clothes,
there were no bathrooms,
there was no food.
So in a way I had been
prepared for this moment,
possibly because I had reported war,
but this was longer than war.
This was just longer.
And it reminds me, actually,
I'll end with that story,
it reminds me of a nurse that
I met in a hospital in Bombay.
And on 26\11, which was India's 9\11,
when terrorists came into
Bombay, the city of Bombay,
and there was a three day siege,
two of them entered
this hospital in Bombay.
And this nurse had been on neonatal duty,
so she was on duty in a war
where there were all these
new mothers and their babies.
And when these terrorists came
in with their assault rifles,
she switched off all the lights,
and she had the presence of mind
to take away all the phones,
and turn them off, and
somehow managed to save lives.
And then she was on COVID duty.
And I remember meeting her and I said,
"Which is tougher."
And she said, "Look, there
are apples and oranges,
but this is so long, I
think it'll ever end,
at least that night ended."
Right?
And I think for me
both are the most meaningful
work that I've done,
both are the scariest work I've done,
both have transformed me personally
at different stages in my life,
but both teach you the same lesson.
What is the job of a journalist?
The job of a journalist
is to go to a place
that your audience cannot access
to ask the questions that
your audience wants to know,
but may have nobody asking,
but also to ask the questions
that nobody else is asking.
And you have to do all
three and be that bridge.
And therefore the lesson from
both stories is the same.
That is my role as a reporter.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Barkha.
That was an amazing hour and a bit,
and I'd invite everyone to come outside,
and join us to talk to Barkha
in a more informal setting now.
- Thank you everyone for coming,
and thank you to everyone online.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)